okie dokie our room eNOS is the opponent
maybe come on let's switch back to a
Sicilian and do something else they're
playing this slower line here positional
line and this is not particularly
threatening from black pattern I am I
like to play this line when i when i get
to get to the night of it sir it's
relatively simple to play and it's
rather strategic it's not so crazy let's
say and if you like i have chances to
find stuff over the board even with my
very limited only for experience so what
what what are you saying here and yeah i
don't i don't quite follow um I can take
here and take d6 but then f2 is hanging
can also take be four
be for a 59 back to d5 that is
compensation okay maybe it is I mean you
gain some tempe but my pieces are pretty
good i mean i have 94 here i can take
you five and play night before maybe and
94 yeah maybe so let's do this it was
maybe a bit cheeky to grab that party
but yeah that's a no risk no fun kind of
situation I'm already taking a risk by
playing the open Sicilian which is not
not really something that I know no well
I mean I really have my every have
doubts that this is that this is good
for black or anything but it said it's
not my usual territory
I just need like 12 moves and
consolidate king be one Bishop f 3 yards
almost like that and it's really am
fizzling out for him now I can take
these six here
what is that is that too much can also
take a five take f6 then something likes
you for that looks now they don't really
think he has as much their check and now
see form
sacrifices on savoia that that's
basically what is reduced to but if it
works it works I mean really
22 Quincy five back threatening f5
I really really want to play a 5
objectively speaking this is probably
just a flat-out waiting for a white but
it's still bit tricky Wow okay why can I
not take I think i canna and then these
three are I mean look the files also a
come on next to this that's it's just
very simple enter and doing the job to
two pawns that no compensation
whatsoever
yeah when did they should really just do
the job those two pods my route d8 was
quicker but we cannot really prevent it
check check check black resigns if ok I
was a rare open Sicilian but I am want
to know why you have to do something
different so this is this young and now
we went to hear that's actually what the
engine does suggest huh yeah it was a
bit cheeky to take that porn but I
couldn't really see exactly what the
compensation is it means to gains a bit
of time but well from a development
point of view are not in bad shape I
mean I've got everything in play night
here c3 i think i have to do it there
before and d4 has to be protected a 3 b3
this the 90 and white has a create the
computer wants to do this that's
probably interesting at try to use the
pin and make sure that I'm not getting
in lights you for so early on computer
says equal yeah well equal in a in a
very unclear way black definitely has
chances they're grabbing that poorness
is risky and this I think doesn't work
really
okay the engine once Jeff grab this yeah
I way I saw that but I wasn't sure I
always thought that he might have
something on b3 them I thought that this
ship would be rather clear yeah okay the
engine is on +1 the thing is if he is
not really getting something going there
quickly with some kind of sacrifice I'm
just winning this thing like a queen
tradewinds instantly and so on and now
FYI thought would be pretty strong yeah
he has to go at five and then g4 is also
strong yeah so I played a decent game I
think and now the engine wants to take
huh it gives it so it doesn't even seem
so clear haha wait wait wait wait wait
so what do I why system and if I take
with the bishop this one wow what a
crazy line yeah it's a spin Dallas is
pinned wow this is on the computer says
I have to take with this and then route
be eight is enough for a draw
welcome to the world of computer chess
okay we'll be tuning of it okay I can
always draw myself them at this this
right here even worth so that means that
wasn't all that grade and I have to take
on f5 instead I like that movement that
seemed very very powerful and again
against he can take on this is just not
working I think I kept a queen g5 check
yeah I can play Queen g5 check that's
ridiculous yeah okay i was just saying I
was just seeing that this is a very
easily winning end game so I didn't
really look any further okay well thanks
for watching